now Shh what does perpendicular mean it
means they realize a new word starts
with I today is white intersect at they
intersect in a special way for instance
these lines are not perpendicular my B's
words are how do we describe it it meets
at a special angle it's a writing it's
running so how do we draw them I mean
like that was wrong how do we actually
precisely correct all choice
okay everyone pins down
he broke pins down by the time I
finished this so watch carefully
actually okay just watch this will be
all the video so you gonna reconvene 40
and then you can do the exercise on
which this is based
I'm waiting forever honor have they
think that so that I'm still waiting
still waiting waiting
okay I'm gonna draw a line that's
perpendicular to a B and it goes through
P so there's gonna be a right angle
right there okay watch compass point
okay that's good CB compass point at
that point okay
and I'm gonna join shoot ox one on this
side okay
so I've rubbed off a little bit let me
put it back obviously if I throw it all
the way I would have gotten like a
semicircle another taper couples going
to make it a little bit longer okay you
do actually need to change it for this
one okay I'm going to draw two arcs to
the same length one for baby here and
one from over here I guess I should name
them it's calling this X all this wine
let me draw an aqua mix and a knock from
Y same link okay watch okay an angel
sent now look
I'm basically done see where this point
meets up here I'll call it Q if you join
PQ that tends to be their very last step
they're like this
how's it look perpendicular I'm sorry
it's pretty much